you know dr. King was but dr. King was a
great speaker and they said oh the jokes
are he couldn't organize himself out of
a paper bag
but see he didn't have to because I only
had to do was figure out the theory he's
with you he's marching so why was he's
necessary to do the day-to-day work but
in Du Bois he's organizing he's not
doing he's not writing the leaflets it's
not today to organize is it's quite
simple you I don't know all the stuff
you hashtag or you you know you tweeted
something like that come after then
people come out but this is a different
day one has to do leafless and has the
development they have to buy the paper
in there to set the leaf is there to set
the print and get there and get to leave
and then have to go out and distribute
him so it's not as easy as there was
before one wants to find a movement
online pentathlete one has to get up and
go to paris and go to these other
countries and meet these leaders and so
he has this unique ability to organize
but in a different way by true intellect
and and of course as you look at it his
work I be missing without saying that
Dubois is one of the early writers on
the condition of african-american women
he has a great appreciation of the role
of african-american women he ruled other
books dark water dogs princes and many
others he appreciates and why I suppose
for the same reason I do because it was
raised by a single mother and he was
raised and he saw how hard she worked to
produce for him so I always had that
great offense Joyce so he's making this
list his part in jest he says it but he
does have great and then he of course
has a daughter Dubois Dubois a first
name Berger the son and then his his
daughter and then even it when he
marries again Shirley Graham he has a
great appreciation for for that and this
has one more question why do you suppose
the boy saw the need to leave America
it's very complex
he's fought he's been he's fought
participated in struggle around world
war war to the founding of the United
Nations he writes books he goes down
south to stop and innings but then at a
certain point he feels necessary to
leave
no-one's ever feel that way but he felt
and this says to leave at the age of
patch 91 and what's happening during
that time what's happening in the early
60s just and and it's and concurred in
another side what is happening to the
civil rights movement but the great
period of political repression that
starts with McCarthy period starts in
the early fifties starts right after
World War two is ended and lasts
regeneration where people like Dubois
the rest of Paul Robeson's passport is
taken where my godfather Jack that was
put in a jail and did some running
underground which meant he didn't see
his wife for four or five years as he
has to go and live in a farm somewhere
in in Idaho because the FBI is chasing
him because he's accused of being a
communist and perhaps he was never buddy
had to sign lawyers law so it's great
period of political repression you have
other things the Bay of Pigs and an
invasion and cube Americans
contradiction with the Russia that has
been instead lies the space race all of
those things but thousands of blacks
those passports are taken many of the
night.the jobs one that's a sign of
lords the oath have you ever are you now
have you ever been if you saw the movie
Trumbo you saw what is happening
Hollywood many great writers are
blacklisted lose jobs and a great period
of political oppression and so Dubois
feels that in fact enough credit is not
given to Martin Luther King because
there's a civil rights movement and it's
fighting and bringing in people like Bob
Dylan and Pete Seeger and Dick Gregory
and Harry Belafonte and many other
leaders like that across the board it
helps bring in us again the end of the
Cold War but here's a lead because of
that in n Dubois our
goes to Africa but he goes there with
the mission that he always wanted that
was to write this magazine write this a
book or encyclopedia Africana so within
with that and have a nice break and
think about what you're gonna write your
next papers on and and always when you
write your next papers hope they're
better than the first ones
and they would always be and thank you
so and I'll give papers I'll give you
papers out today and then we can discuss
them okay join us every Saturday evening
at 8:00 p.m. and midnight Eastern as we
join students in college classrooms to
hear lectures on topics ranging from the
American Revolution to 9/11 lectures in
history are also available as podcasts
visit our website c-span org slash
history slash podcasts or download them
from iTunes
next on American history TV author
Anthony pitch discusses his book the
last lynching howl a gruesome mass
murder rocked a small Georgia town he
talks about the 1946 mass lynching of
four african-americans in Monroe Georgia
the FBI investigated the murders and the
case went to a grand jury but no one was
convicted the National Archives hosted
this hour-long event
in the last lynching Anthony as pitch
makes use of almost 10,000 official
documents from the FBI and the National
Archives to reconstruct the tragic
events that led to the 1946 murders of
four African Americans on a bridge in
rural Georgia and the push for federal
anti-lynching laws Morris Dees
co-founder and chief trial counsel at
the Southern Poverty Law Center praised
the book for containing quote amazing
research on the barbarity of Jim Crow
South and vigilante justice and CNN's
senior legal analyst Jeffrey Toobin said
it quote tells a haunting story that
sadly looks more relevant and new all
the time
unquote Anthony as pitch is the author
of many non-fiction books including our
crime was being Jewish
hundreds of Holocaust survivors tell
their stories they have killed papa dead
the road to Ford's Theatre Abraham
Lincoln's murder and the rage for
vengeance and the burning of Washington
the British Invasion of 1814 he is a
former Associated Press staffer in
London and their broadcast editor in
Philadelphia a senior writer in the
books division of US News and World
Report and has reported from Israel and
Africa following his lecture in Q&A he
will be signing books one level up in
front of the archive store would you
please welcome Anthony s pitch back to
the National Archives
[Applause]
well good hello everybody I'm glad to
see you managed to take time off to come
in here this I have concentrated on
American history in the last five books
and they all have to do with catastrophe
that's what I'm attracted to I still
think in the closing years of my life
that my book they have killed papa dead
is the best ever written on Lincoln's
assassination as sometimes we didn't
wonder if I wrote it but at this age
I've no reason to project false modesty
or to brag this book I had wanted to
write about a lynching since 1998 and I
couldn't find a lynching that had
documentary evidence to back it up I
found one in Salisbury Maryland it would
interested me but all the court records
had been destroyed so there was nothing
to write about nothing to research
eventually I found this lynching and it
struck me as different in many respects
first of all it was a mass lynching for
a victimless and secondly one of the
victims was a world war ii veteran and
that shocked me
I wondered how on earth they could do
this to a veteran of World War two so
soon after the war so I said about at
the six years ago and there was so much
material to go through as you've heard
ten thousand documents mostly under the
Freedom of Information Act from the FBI
and the National Archives and I have not
wanted to solve it in fact I don't but I
wanted to portray it because in order to
appreciate American history you have to
see it warts and all you have to see the
glory of Washington and they
and others and you have to see the scars
of the lynching and the evil side of
life lynching would expose corrupt or
ease it would show rogue actions it
would pit innocence against vigilantes
and there was so much that I wanted to
tell on this and that's why I decided to
do it I went down to Georgia to see the
annual reenactment which promoted by an
organization called the Georgia
Association of black elected officials I
don't approve of it
I don't sanction it I think it's
disgusting but they have the First
Amendment right and people on the Mars
Ford Memorial Committee who don't agree
with it they recognize their right to
say it
and said why when I was there I saw some
terrible things
I was taken around by two guides one
happened to be a veteran civil rights
activist who had survived firebombing
jail and other Horrors in his quest to
report and see these evil sides he took
me to the homes of some of the
grandchildren of the suspects and he
said we will not stop here we will go
slowly but the won't stop it would be
too dangerous and my other guide was
rich Rusk he was the son of the former
Secretary of State Dean Rusk who Mudd
interviewed 30 years earlier and rich is
a clone of his father it looks just like
him
and he is nice and rich took me around
to many of the sites we went to a church
on Sunday where many of the suspects had
worshipped and wanted to see what it was
like
and when we came out the hood of his car
was opened and he said look if anything
happens to me it was nice knowing you
nothing of course did happen and then I
went around the cemetery and I saw the
graves all tidy and quiets and meet of
the suspects and now many of the
suspects and it was a revelation now to
write about lynching I had to be
faithful to what I've found and what I
reported it was a horrible side of the
history but I had to do it
how Constitution the Declaration of
Independence says that everybody has a
right to life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness and the Bill of Rights firmly
says that everybody is entitled to due
process of law these people were killed
like wildlife and they had no witnesses
they had no court trial they were really
treated with disgust and ignominy and
they were put down honestly like
wildlife that's why I had to report it I
used the N word throughout throughout
the book
it's a degrading ugly word that has no
place in our modern lexicon but I use it
because nothing so portrays the past as
the language in common use at the time
in other words it is not words heard
from our ears at this present time
it's what it was like at that time to
have glossed over it would have denied
these people the right to show the slurs
and indignities that they had to endure
and that's why I use it I make no
apology for using it I had to show what
it was like in 1946 in rural Georgia and
I used the word lid throughout lynched
according to the dictionary definition
is a murder by mob action without a
lawful trial now Morris Dees head of the
Southern Poverty Law Center asked me not
to use the word lynched and of course I
told the publisher that this was not
acceptable but I have no say there's a
publishing convention that the publisher
has the right to set the title of the
book I would not have used it but it was
used by the court officials the FBI the
White House the Justice Department
journalists all kinds of people they
used the word and therefore I use the
word no that was my way of introduction
I said about this and as I said it took
a long time because there were 10,000 of
about 10,000 documents to go through on
the 25th of July 1946 an agitated farmer
telephoned a deputy sheriff in rural
Georgia to report that four blacks had
been dragged from his car and murdered
they were shot when the word reached the
sheriff he first continued on a faith
meal until it finished and only then
joined the deputy sheriff
for the ride out to the crime scene when
they got to the bridge at Moore's Ford
they walked down to the thick
undergrowth near the lazy Appalachia
River that's when they saw the
stiffening bodies of two men and two
women they had been shot multiple times
leaving
ghastly wounds that shredded their flesh
and cracked their skulls
nobody had tried to run and many of them
were shot as they lay down the year
Norman was so overwhelmed by the sight
that they raced back to Monroe Georgia
to summon a coroner's jury leaving a
crime scene unprotected they came back
with the jurors and the farmer Roy
Harrison had been driving their victims
and he said that about 24 anonymous
armed men had ambushed them at the
bridge had dragged out the victims and
shot them and when he told the mother of
George and Dorothy that their children
are being shot dead she slumped down in
a faint now about 35 men women and
children came forward to gawk at the
carnage and nobody told them to back off
the farmer Roy Harrison identified the
victims starting with Roger Malcolm whom
he bailed out of jail just over a
quarter of an hour earlier he said Roger
had agreed to work on his farm and he
was taking them all back to their home
he then identified Rogers mother Roger's
wife Dorothy her brother George Dorsey
and
his wife may all were in their twenties
I should have said earlier that I had a
stroke recently and it affected my
balance that's where I walk with a cane
and it affected also my hearing I'm hard
of hearing and my short-term memory so
when later you asked questions with the
microphone in front of you I probably
went here and there bit somebody in
front yard to tell me what it was but I
beg your indulgence on that I never used
to have notes I hate having notes as a
speech but I have nurturance now
and so the jurors cut the ropes which
were tying the male's together and they
pocketed segments to take home as
keepsakes
the bailiff even took home as a souvenir
a bullet taken from one victims abdomen
and Rogers the rope around his neck had
been dyed so tightly that when it was
cut off the impression was left on his
torn skin much of his face had been shot
off groups of on rockers rushed forward
to grab souvenirs even as the four
victims were taken off to a funeral home
and in the days to come many more people
would stop by looking for mementos even
prying loose bullets which were embedded
in tree trunks a few days earlier they
grant Rogers grandmother had taken the
black Undertaker aside and said if
anything happened to a grandson she
wanted him to look after the body now
that same grandson they stretched out in
front
awaiting the respect he promised the
elderly lady there were at that time the
radio airwaves crackled that night with
reports of what had happened of the
massacre and it was they said that these
unknown people are damn bushed their car
at a bridge at sunset in the Georgia
boonies it was taught and rapid the kind
of copy that radio thrived on
I know because decades ago I was The
Associated Press broadcast Everton
Philadelphia and that's what they like
but they'd rushed to broadcast this
account of their scoop without checking
and if they had checked they would have
found out that the the what is it named
Joey Harrison Lloyd Harrison the farmer
was not a kind farmer as they described
him he was in fact he had a long record
of criminal activity including time
served in the penitentiary and he was
known as a ruthless employer who had a
long history of repetitive brutality and
frenzied violence towards black men and
women he owned a nearby farm which he
operated untrammeled just like a feudal
lords wearing of peasants as docile as
the crime took place in a small walton
county seat of Munro it was such a small
town that a visitor could drive a car
down the built-up area of the main
street in slightly longer than it took
to fill up the car's tank with gas there
was a sense of language ease to this
urban center for the surrounding farming
community the red brick county
courthouse overlooked the town with
aging Authority as if mindful of its
role as the keeper of a settled way of
life and from its front grounds Rose the
statue of a Confederate soldier in
memory of those who fought in defense of
the south and Civil War a conflict that
was still known to locals as the War of
Northern Aggression evidence later
compiled by the investigators showed
that most of the suspects must have come
from Hester tongue a neighborhood seven
miles southeast of the center of town
Hester town was so named because many
people were descended from or related to
a family called Hester many of them were
illiterate and Hester tongue the people
who lived were not only literate but
they owned farms that had patches of
vegetables small acreages of cotton and
a few dairy herd
in marriage between those who were
closely related to one another was not
uncommon
Hester Tong had evolved into a
neighborhood that was clannish in turf
and was a bastion of rigidly uniform
outlook that was where Raja Malcolm had
stabbed a white man in Hester tongue but
it had a darker side to it there was an
observer who said they treated their
farmhands and household staff like
horses and mules there were ardent
churchgoers and they found no
contradiction and worshiping at churches
that preached a creative goodwill to all
races while they believed in what
dominance
now the stabbing took three took place
three days before georgians went to vote
in a primary election statewide for
governor and the state was boiling over
with racist rants it was only recently
that the Supreme Court had lifted the
ban on black voters as a result a former
governor Eugene Talmadge who was now
running for a fourth non consecutive
term stiffened his resistance and he
he was the kind of person who incited
boisterous crowds to the edge of
reckless enthusiasm he made no bones
about where he stood he presented
himself as the white people's candidate
to use the n-word often and he said if
reelected he would reimpose the ban on
black voters in that kind of person and
we're still his followers
disenfranchised tens of thousands of
black voters on the grounds of literacy
or competency to vote they his people
I think one of those moments when I have
a blank Roger had been in jail for a
week languishing there and he told the
man who had raised him from childhood
that he did not want to get out because
it was afraid of what they would do to
him
rumors swirled that vigilantes would
break in and take his life
but Roger had stabbed a white man and in
Georgia in 1946 he may as well have
committed suicide one local observer
said that quote if a black man got
involved in altercation or an encounter
with a white man it was the same as a
death sentence against him but everybody
was duped into thinking that everything
was fine and okay
the law arason told his passengers to go
and shop in Monroe and meet him back at
the courthouse at 5 o'clock in two hours
they went away he said happy and
contented that Roger would soon be
bailed out of jail he himself he said
occupied the two hours by trying to get
his car repaired greeting a few friends
doing some grocery shopping and swapping
small talk with friends at the town's
ice plant his movement seemed to be
routine and harmless but as he took him
back he said he thought they had been
drinking
although autopsies later proved
otherwise
he said they were talking louder and
quicker than they used to but they all
seemed happy and contented
a quarter of an hour later they arrived
at Moore's Ford bridge the single lane
going over the bridge and that was when
Harrison said that anonymous people
ambushed them and they asked everybody
to put their hands up and then they
dragged out the two black males ripped
them together dragged them down to the
undergrowth near the river and in
Harrison said he thought he heard
Rodgers say might I'm done come one of
the women according to Harrison
recognized an ambush and yelled out his
name and so anonymous men then grabbed
the two women dragged him out and hauled
them down to weather mates were and they
were all butchered by gunfire Harrison
said he didn't recognize any of the
ambushes nor could he remember the name
of the ambush I yelled out by the woman
so they let him go and he fled back to a
store to telephone the deputy sheriff
about the massacre now as you can
imagine this lauter created national
headlines and then international
headlines even more so when they
discovered that one of the victims was a
decorated veteran of World War two
George Dorsey outraged veteran veterans
cried out for justice for the loss of
one of their end and people asked how it
is possible that the barbarity of the
enemy in World War two could have found
a place in the land of the victors
30,000 letters of protest and anger
flooded the White House the Justice
Department and the FBI and one black
veteran said that he and people of his
race wondered whether the sacrifices had
been worth it
a letter arrived at the White House from
a black preteen in the West Coast and
she said her people had fought and died
for America as well as any other tribal
Senate in the US Senate
southerners grouped together in
beleaguered defense they accused
outsiders of trying to make political
capital out of this crime just because
blacks were involved and it happened in
the south they said that crimes of equal
brutality in other states were never
given as much publicity President Harry
Truman expressed horror and the Attorney
General ordered an immediate and a full
investigation by the FBI
there was a White House vigil of people
who protested this brutality they stood
in front of the White House and in
distance San Francisco people of both
races march silently down Main Street
Market Street holding placards one of
the placards read Quattro canal 42 North
Africa 43 Germany 44 our Kanawa 45
Monroe Georgia 46 the nation erupted in
fury demanding the immediate arrest of
members of the lynch mob now the FBI had
been held in high esteem at that time
because they had finally brought to heel
the gangster Al Capone the blank our
bank manager Abba John Dillinger and
other crooks and mobsters but in this
case they endured shame and disgust
because of the clumsy ineptness of the
lead FBI investigator J Edgar Hoover
director of the FBI
motored that man sending him to another
state at a reduced salary for not
obeying orders and of course the man
immediately handed in his revolver and
resigned but in the meantime 39 hours
had expired before a pair of FBI agents
arrived at the scene of the crime and in
the meantime literally hundreds of
people had come in to take away much of
the evidence the proof of their presence
was a flattened brush their footprints
on the tire marks 20 agents FBI agents
arrived at Monroe to investigate and
that was equivalent to a mid-sized FBI
field office it was a clear indication
of the priority which the Justice
Department gave to a quick resolution of
the case but the FBI had to go in pairs
for their own protection they were
looked upon as interlopers who should
mind their own business and not meddle
in local affairs and the people the
whites saw them as a threat to a fixed
way of life that a barely changed since
the Civil War the KKK had been active a
decade earlier in Monroe and vicinity
and now they were busy recruiting new
members so they closed ranks the whites
they didn't say very much little or
nothing a white justice of the peace
actually told the FBI that he hoped it
would not be solved because he said in
his words this is a deterrent to uppity
blacks unquote
they even slanted the FBI accusing them
of barging into homes of parsley clothes
women and threatening them while they
searched for evidence they refused many
of them refused to sign their statements
to the FBI or deliver up their guns and
the FBI had no jurisdiction to demand
otherwise few farmers disguised their
belief in white dominance or tempered
their feelings with ambivalence now the
black sharecroppers and the household
staff were no different
they said little or nothing they were
terrified they were intimidated and
threatened they were scared of reprisal
and they said that even those who were
brave enough to blab to the FBI said
there's no way they could talk in an
open court and give testimony the FBI
spent grueling hours on this but there
was so much intimidation and threats
that it was not surprising that Talmadge
was elected and they couldn't make a
breakthrough
now there were stymied from the
beginning because in order to get
jurisdiction the FBI had to prove a
conspiracy between the killers and
Georgia state officials or Georgia
Norman failing that they wouldn't have
jurisdiction and they couldn't demand
that these peoples on their statements
or deliver up their weapons they were
working really with it dies hands tied
behind their backs
they knew it was obvious what time
Harrison and the sheriff and his
deputies would bail out Roger from jail
and they also had time enough to round
up a posse of vigilantes to tell them
the approximate time that Harrison would
arrive at malls for bridge but one of
the investigators wrote to Washington
the FBI headquarters and he said that
their stories were holding up Harrison
and the sheriff stories were holding up
and all of them were plausible now to us
may seem ridiculous but that was what
they reported the Georgia Bureau of
Investigation would normally have
investigated a state crime like murder
but they didn't have a staff or one
skills they didn't have the resources or
the manpower to do this so they deferred
to the FBI which was much superior to
them in all those fields and as time
went on the FBI was accused of bungling
the case fury turned to ridicule one
newspaper even accused the FBI of
capturing elusive the most elusive
criminals but they couldn't even track
down a few backcountry Georgia murderers
J Edgar Hoover simmered in one of the
letters he wrote to his inner circle and
that quote we are doing all all most of
the work but when the time comes for the
case to be broken some Georgia
politician is going to do all or most of
the talking in other words he said if
the case is lost the FBI will get the
brickbats
and if the case is won the FBI will be
out of the picture it was a case of
damned if we do and damned if you don't
he did let this case go on for four
months after the massacre and a reason
was he thought that in that time one of
the people might one of the mob might
break ranks and name a state official
which would give the FBI the conspiracy
the jurisdiction they needed and he also
thought that the power of an oath had a
very very strong appeal to the people to
the suspects in other words they might
say things that they would otherwise not
disclose and a good prosecutor might
even trap them into saying things that
they didn't want to say the same applied
to Jay to lawyer Harrison they were
hoping that he would be able to he would
be forced to say something more than it
already said about what he did in the
time between bailing out Roger and
arriving at the ambush seemed they were
hopeful that a grand jury might have
this kind of effect on the principal
suspects
the Buddha's name Harrison admitted
stopping by at the ice plant to talk to
friends but he denied talking to James
Verner or knowing him
James Verner was an out-and-out arch
white supremacist he was a former Army
Air Corps marksman who thought nothing
of firing a shotgun and other weapons in
the directions of blacks or shouting at
them not to vote in other words keeping
them away from the polls and Harrison
denied absolutely denied that he talked
to this man the Attorney General then
wrote a letter to Jay ago Venice had
Edgar don't you think that our presence
in Monroe should continue until we find
out if you know until we find out if
somebody can implicate the state
officials and Hoover agreed and then the
Attorney General said let's have a grand
jury
Hoover bowed to rank and he told his
subordinates that they would be having a
grand jury
now that grand jury met for 16 days in
December of 1946 and they were made up
of 21 whites and only two blacks and it
was four months after the massacre so
they'd be given a lot of time to get
evidence but they delivered a verdict
that was unanimous they didn't identify
anybody nobody at all and this was as
you can imagine a great shock to
everybody
they only indicted one man for perjury
and that charge was later withdrawn so
in other words everybody went free
now the repercussions were horrific a 19
year old black man called Lamar Howard
insisted on testifying at the grand jury
even though his life his putting his
life on the line documents that I
managed to get Declassified showed that
he had told a grand jury that he saw Roy
Harrison deep in conversation with James
Verner less than an hour before the
massacre he was adamant on that and then
he said he saw James Verner carrying two
pistols to the house plant shortly
before or shortly after the massacre
that was really putting his life on the
line
James Verner and his younger brother Tom
verdure two weeks later arrived at the
ice plant and they took James
they took Lamar Howard aside and said
that they wanted to know what he told
the grand jury they took him to the back
of the ice plant to a cow shed and there
they beat him with clenched fists they
rammed his head against the wall and
they hammered him with a loaded revolver
his clothes were blood-red from the
beating and his eye sockets of his eyes
were pummeled purple but he didn't say
anything about a gun because it was
afraid if he did they would kill him
the venez on a tip from some unknown
person were arrested by law officials
and in charged the meantime when James
when Lamar Howard got home his brother
was looking out the window and he said
mama what's wrong with his face she
jumped out of bed and she said what's
wrong and he said I got beat up while
ago who did it mr. James and mr. Tom did
it why they beat me up because I
wouldn't tell them what I told at the
grand jury so they were arrested and a
meantime a white farmer they were
charged with assault of battery and
meantime a white farmer had told the
black Undertaker who'd seen to the
corpses that every black person who had
testified at the grand jury or who was
going to give evidence at the trial of
the venner brothers should exile
themselves from Georgia rise otherwise
he said it would all be found shot
when the case appeared in court
Tom Verner was found not guilty James
Verna told the court that he had beaten
up Lamar hard because Lamar had run him
off the road with his car and that yuuri
believed him and he was acquitted the
Attorney General the state Solicitor
General said that this was a bad jury
because many of the people on it were
members of the histor town community
there was nothing you could do about
that can't deny everybody a seat on the
jury and the Atlanta daily world which
was a preeminent amongst black
newspapers crusading for civil rights
said that the jury returned the verdict
only because of the race of Lamar Howard
that year later that year James Tom
Vernon died in a car crash and James
Verna was murdered five years later now
when disappeared I filed a court action
demanding the transcripts of the grand
jury because the people who testified
them what they said would be crucial to
my book I couldn't do it myself but I
was very lucky a lawyer Joe Bell from
Bell she wasn't for sale or Rockaway New
Jersey he came forward and offered to
represent me pro bono
free of charge he had three assistants
and they all worked without demanding
payment at all I befriended you many
years earlier when he came and my one of
my Lincoln assassination tours a very
very good man they found a great brief
and it seemed that we had a good chance
of succeeding because
the lead investigator wrote immediately
after the grand jury dissolved he wrote
to Washington saying that he understood
transcripts of the grand of the
testimony of the grand jury were being
sent to Washington now when the case got
to court district court him in Georgia
the US Attorney is said that he didn't
know of any transcripts existing he said
that even if they did things of that age
certainly didn't survive
and the judge appeared to agree because
there was nothing in the court before
the court that would indicate that the
grand jury transcripts existed you see
the pivotal wording of the lead
investigator in his letter to Washington
was I understand transcripts have been
sent to Washington I understand in other
words he wasn't sure and I know that
they couldn't have survived in Atlanta
because I found a letter that was
misfiled and it said that in this letter
was written 1991 it said that the
everything to do with the Mars Ford
massacre had been destroyed in Atlanta I
do by by that but I don't by the fact
that they say that the transcripts
didn't exist in Washington no elsewhere
and so the that's where we stand today
waiting for the Justice Department to
reply to my lawyers to find out if the
transcripts or anywhere within the
federal government in another place
times have changed very much the Moores
Ford memorial committee was created by
people of both races and they laid
plaques beside or near the graves of the
four victims each of them read May or
suffering
be may your suffering be redeemed by
contraband by the wording of that
brotherly love
may your suffering be redeemed by
brotherly love they raise funds to endow
scholarships in memory of the dorsey's
and Malcolm's and the attitudes have
also changed since then
nowadays law enforcement officials
linked arms with others who are crossing
the bridge in memory of those who have
fallen there on the honorary board of
the malls for local chimeric committee
and they block major intersections
allowing participants in the annual
reenactment to go forward now I close
with this 153 years after the massacre a
yellow by plane flew high over the grave
of George Dorsey of the decorated
veteran of World War two in memory in
tribute to this veteran this was would
have been unthinkable the stuff of
dreams in 1946 and these the mourners
sang
I can't remember the name of that song
of goodness sake it's you know the one
way your sing in memory of somebody has
fallen anyway they're saying that and
then the soldiers presented a folded
flag to a nephew and they they in other
words they paid homage to this great man
and George Dorsey is sister-in-law was a
lady called Ruby and she said she was
incredulous when she said this she said
I never ever thought it would happen
thank the Lord I live to see it thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
so I have a question over here at the on
your right and I think it's a great
story I've been aware of it for a long
time especially the great story being
the the Morris Ford committee but I have
a problem with your title you say the
last lynching what would you tell to the
family of Mac Charles Parker in
Mississippi or of Emmett Till or of the
three civil rights workers murdered in
Neshoba County don't those at least two
of those three incidents don't they
count as lynchings and aren't they in
the 1960s you are absolutely right
absolutely I know it wasn't the last
lynching it was the last mass lynching
and I know I also know that it didn't
Rock and small Georgia town only it
rocked a nation and it created
international headlines I put this - the
publisher and a publisher has the right
to choose the title and they said that
the word mass a mass gruesome mass
lynching would describe how it differed
from all the others
now it doesn't differ much from those
three civil rights workers who were
murdered in the 1960s but that is what
happened the publisher chose the title
and I had no recourse to change it you
are absolutely right
nobody else that must be
Tony I wonder if you could put things in
perspective being a native of England
can you think of anything in England
that would approach American lynchings
first and for the 1946 lynching how
unique was it
I remember at the arena theater seeing
the tallest tree and I believe there was
a reference to this specific lynching
had lynching died out in the United
States by the post-world War two period
good question rod lynching had
diminished but it didn't die out it was
any recently that a black man was
dragged behind a truck in Texas so it's
still going on now to find an analogy in
England I mean I was a schoolboy in the
1950s and I remember very clearly the
Moors began to Samos Ford bridge the
killings on the moors it was horrific
they tortured children and killed them
and there's people one of them was
actually I think better dead now they
were imprisoned they didn't carry out
the death penalty there but I honestly
don't think that anything approximates
what black people went through in
Nanjing you know I cite in the preface a
debate in 2005 amongst people in the
United States Senate and John carrier
was there a senator he thought he said
that lynching was just putting a rope
around somebody's neck and raising him
up on a tree but he said truthfully that
it involves
people going there for sport they used
to take children to look at this and
they would take away like this case they
would take away trophies of ears or
fingers things like that but the men
formaldehyde and those were trophies so
I don't think anything in England
approximates that but death is death I
mean but lynching still going on
no Tony I understand how sacrosanct the
National Archives regards grand jury
testimony regards income tax returns and
I realize that occasionally a judge will
open a grand jury transcript I think
something like that happened with the
Rosenbergs why do you think that if a
transcript could be found in Washington
pursuant to your request
there would be possibility of it being
opened I think age would have something
to do with it I requiring them to be
open you can demand that the secrecy of
grand jury is breached for the public
interest and that's what we would cite
is their question that a grand jury
testimony is secretive because it
protects everybody but in this case it
happened so long ago that I am quite
convinced if we could lay our fingers on
the transcripts that it would definitely
be revealed they would allow me to see
them I'm absolutely sure of that but the
final thing is to find them I don't
think that they they were destroyed I
know that J edgar Hoover's private
secretary Helen Gandy destroyed a lot of
his personal papers